完全たる失望者に生まれてくる感情は何ですかね
ウペッカーなんです 怒りんじょもないんです
怒り生まれるのは何か希望があってそれなくなったんだからなんです
もしかするとその希望が実現できたんではないかということで怒りが生まれてくるんですね
そこで絶望するものは何もないんだと
安心するものは何もないんだと言ったから
腹が立つにも腹が立たないんで
誰に対して腹が立つのかキリがないんだから
腹が立ちたければ やっぱり誰かが味方がもうないと対照しないとね
これが悪いというためにこれが正しいということはないと言えないでしょうに
だからもう気もない 楽もないし苦もないし
ただシャのウペッカーのクールな心が生まれるんですね
やりたいという気持ちもないし
やりたくないという気持ちもないし
このたいというのは消えちゃうんですね
やりたい やりたくないとかね
なんか不思議に なんか人は自分はもうとっくに死んでるんですね
自分はいない やりたいという気持ちもない
大変な不思議な知恵なんです
そのウペッカーの知恵って
でもそれで落ち着くんです
心が あの失望感とかね
恐怖感とかね そういうことで心が激しく揺れちゃったんです
ずっと輪廻の中で安定感探そうと安心しましょうということで
それこそ生きる目的ですよと頑張ってきて
それ自体壊れちゃったんだから
かなりショックなんです
もう輪廻する目的が消えちゃったんですね
結局は 安定感探せなくなっちゃう
だからそのショックも消えちゃって
それで鋭く丸い球形の鏡に全てをするような感じで観察していくと
もうウペッカーがシャが
要は平安な心 安心した安らぎの心が生まれてきて
どっちでもどっちでもいいやという言葉じゃなくて
別にどっちでもということで終わっちゃうんですね
いいやということじゃもうないんですね
それぐらいもないんです
どちらでも受けますよということさえもなく
何もなくウペッカーが生まれてきて
心にまた心のエネルギーが安定しちゃうんですね
次に随順の知恵っていうものが生まれてくるんですね
それはアヌローマニャーナと言うんです
最後は アヌローマというのは随順ということだから
この究極的なシャ 一切の希望が消えちゃって
一切の安心感が消えちゃって
すべて瞬時に見え見え見えてしまっちゃって
それをまたはじけていくだけで
何も取るものもなくて
だからいいんですよとも言えないし
悪いんですよとも言えないし
もうどっちでもいいということになってしまって
で 次の心にはアヌローマ随順と言うんです
何に随順かというと 悟りに随順なんですね
ほぼ悟ったぐらいような心があって
そこの瞬間で生まれるんですね
煩悩ない 何も気持ちがないんだから煩悩はないんですね
何の主観もないんだから
アヌローマっていうのは随順だから
これどちらに随順しているかというと
それから先の悟りの心に随順しているんです
次の心で悟りが開くんです
瞬間に そこまで心が成長しちゃったらもう戻れません
また俗世間に戻りましょうとは絶対無理なんです
またものを見て楽しくてもう仕事をして金儲けていっぱい有名になってというふうな俗世間にはもう戻れません
だからアヌローニャーナが生まれたら
次の瞬間の心は悟りなんです
だからあっという間なんです
ちょっと時間かかる可能性あるのは
このウペッカーニャーナのところです
ウペッカーニャーナっていうのは
このクールな心でまた観察し続けるでしょうに
そこでちょっと心が弱くなったらアヌローニャーナが生まれない
アヌローニャーナのところに行けない可能性もありますけど
やっぱりあんまりここまで行く人はね
そんなまたもうちょっと一息しようっていうことはしませんし
まあ大体一息はさせません
お釈迦様から言えば 例えば
その知恵が生まれてきている
ウペッカーニャーナ その瞬間に
例えば人がピストルを持ってきて自分に撃とうとしているんだと
それでもその場所は動くなと
ウペッカーニャーナになるんだったら
向こうはピストルで撃つかもしれません
だけど その弾が自分の体に届く前に心はものすごい速く変化していくんだから
アヌローニャーナが生まれて悟りの智慧が生まれるんです
動いちゃったらダメなんです
動くためには普通の心を作らなくちゃいけないんだから
じゃあ動きましょうと
心の流れが切れちゃうんです
ですから その時は動かせません
昔あるストーリーがあって
これはもうサーリプッタ尊者の弟子サミ
サミなんですけど 子供なんですけど
で 一緒に托鉢して ところでいろいろサーリプッタ尊者に質問するんですね
子供だから あの人何やってるんですか？あの人たち何やってるんですか？と
サーリプッタ尊者もいろいろ教えてあげながらね
あれは今畑に水をくんでいるんだと
あれの人々は弓を作っているんだとかね
で 説明するんで これはね
こうやって温めてまっすぐにして
こうやってまっすぐに矢を作らないとね
うまく届きませんよとかね
水なんかもこの小さな小さなダムでも作って
こうこうやってコントロールしないと水田はできませんよとか
もう子供だからいろいろ説明しながら托鉢に行って
で いきなりその若いサミが「ああ
やっぱり心も育てなくちゃいかないんだね」と 「
それはそうだよ」と 「
心も育てればニッパナに導き得られます」と
ということで 「じゃあだったら私はまあまあ修行してみますと
だけど子供だから本人でやりたいという気持ちが出さないと
修行させたっても何の意味もない
だから偉大なサーリプッタ尊者のところでお世話になっていたあの子供も
別にサーリプッタ尊者もう大智慧の第一人者だからといってね
この人に厳密に教えてあげようとかね
押し付けようということはなかったんです
一緒に楽しく子供が聞きたいことを聞いてあげたり
見たいものを見せてあげたりとかね
普通にしていたんだけど
当然その子はやっぱり頑張ってみますと言ったら
いいですよと言って瞑想のを教えてあげたんですね
あげたらその子はもう真面目に修行を始めて
托鉢出ることできなかったんです
それでご飯ないんですね
それでサーリプッタ尊者が「じゃあ私は托鉢してご飯持ってきますから
あんた帰って瞑想しなさい」と
言ったらサーリプッタ尊者が托鉢してご飯一杯もらってお寺に帰ろうとしてるんですね
帰ろうしていると その子供がものすごい瞑想も進んでいるんですね
それでお釈迦様が外へ出るんです
外へ出てもうサーリプッタ尊者と喋るんです
いろいろ 「どうですかね」と 「
どこら辺行ってきたんですか？」と
ごく普通なことをいろいろ喋って
だからお釈迦様が話しかけてきたらもう行くわけないし
サーリプッタ尊者困ってるんですね
もう時間なくなっちゃったらね
もう午前中過ぎちゃったら
あの子供にはもうご飯も食べられないし
どうしようかなとかね
で 困ってるんですよ 困ってるんだけど
お釈迦様の前でね そんなこと言えないし
お釈迦様もすごいゆっくりのんびりいろいろ話してるんです
で なぜそういう風にお釈迦様サーリプッタ尊者を邪魔したかというと
その子はこういう智慧のレベルに達しているんですね
だからその場を動かしちゃいけないんです
そこでお釈迦様もまあ大体時間的にわかるんです
あの辺に来たらもうものすごくわかるんです
瞬時にもう成長しちゃうんです
逆戻りなく このレベル全然逆戻りないレベルだからね
成長しますからね まあそろそろ悟り開いたなと思ったところで
お釈迦様なんのことなく「じゃあこの我はあの子供に持ってきたでしょう
ご飯は じゃあ行って差し上げてください
食べさせてください」と
って言っちゃったんです
だからたとえサーリプッタ尊者でも自分の弟子だから 「
じゃあもう瞑想 ご飯食べてから瞑想しなさい」と言っちゃうんです
言っちゃったらこれはもう大変なことだからね
だからお釈迦様が来て
もうサーリプッタ尊者にも気が付かないように
もう邪魔して もう一応ちょっと
それもう邪魔してあげて
それで悟ったところで
もう別に午前中もう午後になったとか
もうそんなお釈迦様にそんなことどうでもいいことで
あの子供にご飯あげなさいと
それよりは大事なことは悟ることだからね
でお釈迦様に言われてるサーリプッタ尊者にもどうしようもないし
まあご飯食べなさい 持ってきましたよと
ちょっとお釈迦様に話があって
途中であって遅くなったんですよと言ったかもしれませんだけど
言わなかったかもしれませんだけどね
で 遅くなってごめんとかね
まあごめんというのは仏教では言いませんだからね
そこでこのスウィジュンチあるいはアヌノーマニャーナが生まれたら
もうほとんどさと悟った人の心とほとんど似ていると
で 心自体は悟った心じゃないんだけど
偽物なんですけど 偽物と本物はもうわからないぐらいもう正確なんですね
それぐらいの心が生まれたら
その心はいくつか続けて次の心のヴィーティ
あのヴィーティの中ですぐ悟りの心が生まれてくるんです
アッパナー心と言うんですけどね
安息心 安息境の心 そこでサマーディの心の流れいう場合は
大体サマーディが生まれる前に使う言葉が三つありますね
例えばサマーディが生まれるとする
それで前の心にはパリカンマと言うんですね
次の心には ウパチャーと言うんですね
次の心にはアヌローマと言うんです
次の心は いわゆるサマーディの心なんですね
で これ瞬間ですけど で
その 1番目の心  2番目の心
3番目の心  4番目のこと
4番目の心で次元が変わっちゃうんですね
例えば 俗世間にいる我々は 第1禅定を作ろうとする
第1禅定を作ったら その人は色界の人なんです
心の次元が変わったんですね
その次元が変わる瞬間
このステージなんですね
パリカンマ心 ウパチャー心
次にアヌローマ心が生まれて
次にサマーディ心が生まれる
サマーディ心と言わない
その代わりに使う言葉はアッパナーなんですね
そこで どんな場合でも心の次元が変わると言われる上に行く
この次元乗り換える瞬間は
このステップで説明するんです
乗り換える瞬間 そうでないと
心はずっと同じ次元で流れていくんですね
それから天国に行っても地獄に落ちても
あの俗世間だから 欲界だからね
心は同じ一方で流れているんですね
天国に行ったんだから心は堕落したということはないし
昇華したわけでもないし
地獄に落ちたんだから堕落するわけでもないんです
同じ欲界の心なんです
この欲界から色界に行く場合は
もう次元変わっちゃうんだから乗り換えなくちゃいけないんです
その乗り換える瞬間はパリカンマ
ウパチャーラ アヌローマ
アッパナーという心の順番
そこで色界の第1禅定にいる人が第2禅定にチャレンジする
それで第2禅定の次元に行く場合も
パリカンマ ウパチャーラ
アヌローマ アッパナーでその乗り換えするんですね
無色界でも同じことで
悟りの世界でもアビダンマでも同じ順番で説明するんです
そこで悟ってない人は普通の凡夫という一般の人なんですね
誰であろうが 心の次元は俗世間の心の次元なんですね
俗世間の心が出世間の心に入れ替える
その場合はパリカンマ
ウパチャーラ アヌローマ
アッパナーの順番に生まれるのです
で そういう言葉の意味は書いていると思いますけど
パリカンマっていうのは一応まあ頑張って修行しているところで
ウパチャーラっていうのは
このサマーディのそれから至るべき境地に近寄ってくる
アヌローマっていうのはほとんど似ているようになる
ちゃうんですね 心が サマーディに
次にサマーディ心が生まれる
これはテキストではこの町に例えていて
村から町に入って町のお祭りしているところに行こうとしているんだと
それで町のお祭りのところにもう頑張って歩いて歩いて行かなきゃいけないんですね
そこで近寄ってくると
この頑張って歩く時間がいかんまなんですね
祭場の方に近寄ってくると
いろいろ音が聞こえるんですね
太鼓の音やら音楽の音やらいろんなもの
で さらに進んじゃうと
もう祭りのその場所に行くんですね
場所の方へ行ったら もういろんなもの見えるんですね
もうほとんど祭りの場に入ったと同じなんですね
次のステップでもう玄関から中に入るんです
ですから 例えばここら辺で盆踊りやってるんだったら
そこまで来た人にとっては
もう自分は盆踊りにほとんど参加しているような感じでしょうに
まだまだ参加してないんです
もうそばまで来ただけで
そばまで来ていたんだから
まあ似ていて似ていない状態なんですね
そこですぐその輪の中に入っちゃったら
もうもうそれで終わりなんですね
そういう感じで心が最終的にアヌローマニャーナ
随順の心になって それから安息状態というのは安息心が生まれるんですね
で アヌローマニャーナが生まれたら
今まで説明してきたヴィパッサナーのアヌローマニャーナ
随順知の場合は随順知の場合
次にもうサマーディの悟りの解脱の心が生まれるんです
ですからニャーナダッサナヴィスッディと書いているんですね
知見生起と それでニャーナダッサナヴィスッディというこの 7番目の生起
生起は 7段階で説明しているんですね
7番目になったということは
もう悟ったということなんです
そこでどう説明すればいいんですかね
チッタヴィッティの前のチャートありましたから
そちらにも書いてあるだろうと思いますけど
ウペッカーニャーナが生まれるんですね
ヴィパッサナーの場合は
それウペッカーニャーナにはサンカーウペッカーニャーナというんです
ココナッツのヴィパッサナーの知恵の最後
私は前はウペッカーニャーナだけ書いたんだけど
正式な名前はサンカーウペッカーニャーナ
9番目 サンカーラっていうのは現象でしょ
一切の行 現象 だからすべての現象についてウペッカー
もう冷静 何もとらわれることもなし
いいも悪いもどちらでも何もない状態の心が生まれてくるんですね
次のここで悟りますけど
その心が生まれたら この心にもう一つ専門の言葉があります
ウッターナガーミニ ヴィパッサナー
ウッターナというのは立ち上がるということ
起きるということ 起きていくという意味なんですね
これどんな訳でしたっけ？出家に至る観ですね
いわゆるもう起きて出て行っちゃうんです
どこから起きて出て行くかというと
現象の世界から立ち上がって
もう離れるという ですから
このウペッカーニャーナ
シャーのチッっていうのはキーポイントなんです
瞑想する人はこのヴィパッサナーのシャーが生まれるまでやらなくちゃいけないんです
そこをシャーが生まれたら次の瞬間で悟るんです
そこはもう究極的なところで
シャーまで行ったら全然逆戻りはない
あのバヤナ法でももう逆戻りはないんだけどね
大体ヴィパッサナーの障害乗り越えたらもう大丈夫なんです
あの十種類の障害ありますね
その障害乗り越えて普通のこんな瞑想に戻られれば
大体その人はもう堕落することはないんです
でも時間いつかかるかわからないんですね
十年か百年かわからないんです
でも道はそれません なぜならば
道と非道の間でもう決断しましたからね
で そこから修行して またこの九つの知恵が生まれたら
もうすぐすぐもう もしかすると二
三分で終わるかもしれませんし
一時間以内に修行終わるかもしれませんし
すぐ悟れちゃうんです
で とにかくサンカーウペッカーニャーナが生まれる
次にゴートラブーニャーナでしたっけ
聞いていいはないか こちらは
これパンチャットワーラ
ドッカに あ 持って 持ってますかね
この この高橋さん作ったこのチャートを
この これ私は読めません
禅の何ですか？これは
道？慈 禅の慈か道 でもこう書いていると
そちらでマッガヴィティというところは悟りの世界の順番なんですね
こちらは明確に書いてます
このチャートあるならば
そのチャートでこのパリカンマ
ヘンサ ピンギョ スウィジュンという心三つ順番にありますね
それはこちらであったパリカンマ
ウパチャラ アヌローマという三つなんですね
その三つはヴィパッサナーの智慧の立場から言えばスウィジュンチなんです
悟りとほとんど似ている
もう悟りの偽のものの心みたいなもんなんですね
次にゴートラブーニャーナという心が生まれるんですね
なんでこの言葉を選んでいるんでしょうかとわからないんですね
とにかくこういうこのゴートラブーニャーナというか
ゴートラブーという心が生まれる
いわゆる次の心にゴートラブーと言うんです
そこでも勝手な解釈いろいろありまして
ゴートラっていうのは家のことなんですね
自分が何々系ですかとかね
佐藤系か田中系か何とかとか
まああるでしょうね 家っていうのはね
で そういうことで ブーっていうのはそれに入っていると
もうあの 皇籍と読むんですか
その皇籍に家系に入りましたということなんですね
そこでどんな家系かなと
ゴートラって まあそれは聖人の聖者の世界に
もうその名簿に名前を入れてくれたという
ブーっていうのはなったということで
ゴートラっていうのは出世性のことですね
それはもう単なる言葉の遊びの解釈で
とにかく意味がわからないんだけど
ゴートラブーニャーナと次の言葉に心に言うんです
そこで終わり このゴートラブーニャーナという心で
世俗的な心の流れが終了するんです
それっきりで その人には世俗的な心が生まれません
これは最後の世俗的な心なんです
ゴートラブーニャーナという心は
ですから 特別に名前を入れてるんです
そうでないとパリカンマ
ウパチャラ アヌローマ
次にはアッパナーサですから
いりませんね そこでアヌローマニャーナ
スウィジュンチはちょっと分けちゃうんですね
スウィジュンの心を分けて
最後のスウィジュンの心にゴートラブーと
もう家系に名前を入れてくれるんだと
その瞬間で まだ家の玄関にいるんですけど 「
じゃあはい 入ってください」というところまでないんですね
だから入ってくださいと言われちゃったらもう入られますから
その最後の一ステップだけゴートラブーと言われるんです
一旦このゴートラブーの心が生まれてしまったら
その人は聖者であって
もう預流果に悟っても構いません
普通だったら預流果ですけど
まあそれからは世俗間の心はまあそれなりにそれなりに生まれますけど
まあ一応聖者であることは確かな
もしこれを阿羅漢であるならば
もう俗世間の心は生まれません
生まれる心は全部ユイサ心と言うんですね
単なる機能のみの心なんですね
煩悩はない ゴートラブーニャーナ
この心の次に生まれる心にはマッガというんですね
マッガというのは道 このマッガ心は道心ですね
道心は出世間心なんです
で この場合はこの悟りとほぼ似ている状態になったし
次の心で煩悩が消えちゃうんですね
もう玄関から家に入っちゃいますからね
もう外の人じゃないんです
だから外にいた時は 例えば連行とやら何か何か家で入ってはいけないものがあったんだから
今まで入れてくれなかったんですね
それでその人は今まで持っていたその家の中に持っていってはいけないものを全部そこで下ろしちゃうんですね
まあ違う もっと違う例で言えば
例えば誰かもう政治家の大臣か総理大臣か
そういう人がいる家に入ろうとしている
なかなか入れてくれないんですね
入りたくたってね それでいろいろその準備するんですね
資格を得るんですね 総理大臣に面会できるように用意があったり
それこれいろいろコンタクト取ったり
いろんな人に話をして
それでじわじわと近寄ってくるんですね
そこで日にち決めちゃったら
自分がそこまで行くでしょうね
行ってもいきなり入ってはくれません
日本がどうか分かりませんだけど
それからこれをカバン持っていってはいけませんと
自分の国だったらね 危ないんだからカバンは持っていってはいけませんと
それで何か例えばピストルとか
もうアメリカだったらね
持っていくでしょうね
で ピストルやらもういろんなものやら
それはそこら辺に全部置いといて
中に入らなくちゃいけない
そんな感じで このマッガっていうのは門ですから
この心が生まれると 煩悩がそこで弾けちゃうんですね
煩悩が弾けるんです なくなっちゃうんですね
だから 1番目の人だったら 3つでしょうし
2番目のサトルだったら 2つは弱くなっちゃうし
3番目のサトルだったらその煩悩 2つもなくなっちゃうし
4番目のサトルだったら残り 5つの煩悩もなくなっちゃうということで
ですからマッガニャーナという心があって
それは出世間の心 マッガニャーナというマッガチッタ
次にパラチッタ パラは果ですね
結果の果 次の心に果というんですね
これ心っていうのは対象がないと生まれません
心っていうのは対象を認識することだからね
で ゴートゥーまでは行
サンカーラを対象としているんです
我々はいつでも認識はしていますけど
何を認識していますかというと
サンカーラを認識しているんです
何か見るということは
それサンカーラでしょうに
聞くということはサンカーラでしょうに
考えるということはサンカーラでしょうに
だから人間の認識っていうのはもうサンカーラ
現象を認識している世界なんです
そこで最終的なこのゴートラブーというか
この まあ大体これはアヌローニャーナだからスウィジュンチ
スウィジュンチ 随順心の場合も
やっぱりサンカーラを見ているんですね
やっぱりサンカーラは無常ですよ
空ですよ 無我ですよと
何もないんだと ただ空っぽやと言っても
その人見ているのはサンカーラなんですね
無常たるサンカーラを見ているんです
今まで無常たるサンカーラ見えませんでしたけど
永遠なサンカーラ見てきたんだけど
この瞬間では永遠なサンカーラではなくて
無常たる瞬間変化していく苦しみである空であるドッカであるアニッチであるサンカーラを見ている
それでもサンカーラを見ているんですね
だからゴートラブーの時もサンカーラを見ているんですね
そこで聞くのはもうあなたサンカーラに対する感情を捨てなさいと
もう捨てられます もう嫌になっているんだから
そこでやっぱりすべて無常だと
もう実体はないんだということで
まあ取れないんだと 私もいませんという気持ちになった瞬間でマッガチット道心が生まれてくる
そこで煩悩がなくなっちゃうんです
煩悩がなくなったのはいいんだけど
次にカシン結果の心が生まれるんです
なぜ煩悩なくなるかというと
この心 2つは随分違うんです
マッガパヤ道果心は随分違う
これは出世間心なんです
これは世間心 ゴートラブーまでは
これだけは出世間心なんです
こんな瞬間なんですけど
長く長く生まれません
これは 長い長い時間は
この出世間心の対象は何ですか？ サンカーラではありません
だからもう言葉にはもう何も言えないんですね
すべて言葉サンカーラだから
今までの経験した一切もう何一つでもないんですね
それ何一つでもない なんか分かりませんだけど
違うものを体験するんですね
だからなんか分からないものを体験するって言っても
仏教では涅槃を対象にして涅槃というニッバーナというもの
あるいは滅ということなんですね
それを対象にして心 2つ生まれるんです
はい だからまあ分かりやすく言えば
ナームルーパのニローダ
ナームとルーパ それはサンカーラのこと
名色ですね そちらのニローダを
体験する ニローダっていうのは滅尽というかね
滅すること だからすべての現象の世界
心の世界のこの滅する
滅したらどうなるかという
滅したその状況を体験するんだから
それは涅槃なんですね
それはやってみなきゃ分からないことでね
絶対言葉では説明できない
で まあ大体修行する人にとっては心が消えたというふうな感じがするんですけどね
心が消えたと 心が消えたというのはありえないことなんですね
心があるという感じは
現象が感じているということなんですね
ですから心が消えたという感じが生まれるんです
ですから こういう言葉に惹かれて私に私は心がなくなったんだとかね
そんなことを言って怒らせないでください
で ごまかしは効かない
この世界では そういう高慢というのは絶対あってはならない
普通のことに高慢があってもね
まあちょっとまあいいわと認めますけどね
これ絶対あってはならない高慢なんです
寝て有分身になってしまって
やっぱり瞬間なんかどうなったか自分でわからなくなったんですよと
自分でわからなくなったら
それ寝ていただけのことなんです
その場合はそうじゃないんです
ものすごく頑張ってきたところで
心も心が消えちゃうんです
で パラニャーナの後でパラニャーナいくつか 2つ
3つぐらい生まれて それから普通の心に戻るんです
ごく普通の心に戻るんです
もう聖者なんです 煩悩がなくなっちゃったんです
ですから 一人の人に輪廻の中で解脱するまで
このマッガチッタというのは 4つしか生まれません
それも一回きり 煩悩は二度と殺せませんだからね
だから 4回で殺すんだから
煩悩は だから 4つしか生まれません
他はこの瞑想するとたまたま生まれてきます